our reporters used to be able to get
ride-alongs during the trump
administration and you all came in and
promised to be the most
truthful and transparent administration
and you all
you know oversee the department of
homeland security so
if you all wanted to grant access to the
press
couldn't you just tell dhs to do it
again we fully support transparency and
i would encourage you to talk to the
department of homeland security about
any requests you have for press access
reporters calling out the white house
for a lack of transparency at the border
as the influx of migrants continues to
grow as you just heard
from griff dhs secretary alejandro
mayorkas visited yesterday but no
cameras
were on him so what is actually
happening down there and why can't
we see it with me now is former acting
department of homeland security
secretary and heritage foundation
visiting fellow
chad wolfe by the way we did reach out
to secretary
mayorkas have not yet heard back we'll
let you know if we do
uh secretary good to see you thank you
for being here what do you think
is this is there an actual cover-up
going on here
well uh the cover-up's questionable but
i will tell you that it is absolutely
shameful that
reporters the media the press and others
cannot tour some of these facilities
i know that dhs has concerns about
privacy issues about covid
related measures but those things are
workable you can get press
into these facilities we did it back in
2019 we did it to
federal uh sorry family residential
centers where we were housing families
and we certainly did it
uh in the donna facility that they have
up and running now and others along that
border it can be done
uh the question is why aren't they why
aren't they allowing press in there
uh to look at some of these facilities
some of them are very well run
by border patrol and by dhs so i think
it's a good news story at the end of the
day for
the department but clearly they're
concerned about something and the fact
that
what about jen i mean jen sachi's in a
difficult position uh
denying that something that certainly
looks for
all the world like a crisis denying that
it is one although she let it slip
out the other day that it was a crisis
but uh
the the she her argument that hhs
is is preventing uh these ride-alongs
from happening
if if if you got one phone call from
president trump when you were
acting director saying look let the let
the press go in these ride-alongs
wouldn't you have had to do it
well absolutely and it wouldn't have
taken a phone call from the president to
do that
the department has an obligation to the
american people to be transparent about
what they do
so having press embedded in some
ride-alongs or in some of these
facilities
now you can't give them 24 7 access and
you can't give them unfettered access
because there are privacy concerns and
other concerns
but you can designate times and you can
get them in there
if you are if you want to do that if you
want to have that transparency and i
would just say that
you know obviously president biden came
in talking about transparency and unity
and i can't think of you know something
less transparent than not allowing press
into a unfolding crisis along our
southern border
we just got these new figures uh of
about 15 000 unaccompanied kids that
were being held
in both dhs facilities or hhs facilities
and and border patrol facilities i'm
going to show you i
i have the cover of a time magazine
article this is from july
of 2018. of course it was totally made
up that
that never happened it was a photo uh
uh op uh decision that time magazine
made for that
uh but wasn't isn't the situation now
even worse than it was when time made up
that cover
as far as unaccompanied alien children
absolutely the number that you showed
in your last segment uh far exceeds the
number
of unaccompanied alien children that dhs
and hhs had
during the 2019 crisis when there was
such outrage
and obviously when that cover was so dhs
right now in cbp
in their custody at the height uh during
the trump administration we had about 26
2700 uacs
today cbp has almost twice as much
not quite twice but almost and so that's
concern and it goes back to the
messaging
that the biden administration is telling
would-be parents and
others in northern triangle which is if
you get your unaccompanied child to the
border they will stay here
in the united states and that is a very
inhumane message
and it's a significant pull factor and
it's why you see
the huge numbers along that border today
i mean the whole point of this time
magazine was to portray president trump
as inhumane i
i agree with you i think it's far more
inhumane
uh to provide a lure of of unaccompanied
children
uh by getting rid of policies that seem
to be stopping
the flow of unaccompanied children
right absolutely i mean that that's what
it is at the end of the day because a
lot of these children don't
qualify for asylum and a lot of the
families don't qualify for asylum
so essentially you're telling you're
selling them a lie we know about 90
percent don't qualify
so what happens is that when they get
released here into the country
then you have to go out and you have to
deport them you have to remove them back
to their home countries which as we know
as you indicated
in your last segment the biden
administration is not enforcing and not
letting ice do their job to do just that
now i'm wondering and i'm going to just
ask you
briefly to talk politically in fact we
only have about 20 seconds but
why do you think this administration is
taking the political cost
of of all this craziness at the border
what what is in it for them
to be able to absorb the political costs
of the crisis
well i think in some respects they are
listening to the far left uh advocacy
groups along that border
and you know obviously they were very
much opposed to what the trump
administration did
securing that border and bringing
integrity back to the immigration system
and i think they've swung so hard and
they tore down a lot of the procedures
and policies that i think a lot of this
surge caught them by surprise
it shouldn't have uh we talked to them
during their transition about the
consequences
that would occur if you pull some of
this back so it shouldn't have been a
surprise but i think
it certainly is and it's why you see
fema and you see these emergency
measures that they're taking they're
trying to get it under control and i
think at this point they've swung too
far to the left trying to appease
that side of their party and it's it's
very unfortunate chad wolfe
uh good it is very unfortunate
particularly for those kids
our heart goes out to them chad well
thank you very much appreciate you
joining us this saturday